انطلاقا من اتفاقيه امميه تحضر النقل
القصري لاطفال المجموعه الى مجموعه اخرى
واتفاقيه تحضر نقل الاطفال الى الخارج
وفق تحقيق اجراه برنامج مرصد الصراع
المدعوم من الخارجيه الامريكيه انتهاك
موسكو للقوانين الامميه عبر برنامج نقل
اطفال من اوكرانيا الى مناطق تخضع
لسيطرتها لكن من هم هؤلاء الاطفال ينقسم
الاطفال المرحلون والبالغ عددهم سته عشر
الفا الى اربع مجموعات مجموعه اخذت من
مؤسسات اوكرانيه تقع في مناطق سيطره عليها
الروس واخرون ارسلهم ابائهم الى معسكرات
صيفيه باداره روسيه ومجموعه اعتقلت
السلطات الروسيه ابائهم اما المجموعه
الاخيره فضمت اطفالا يتم بسبب القتال
ياتي غالبيه هؤلاء الاطفال من مدن جنوبيه
وشرقيه اوكرانيه
طفل يتيم سافروا الى اراضيها بدون مرافق
وتبني عائلات روسيه
400 منهم الا ان مسؤولين عن التحقيق وصفوا
البرنامج المنهجي لاعاده تثقيف وتبني
الاطفال الاوكرانيين بالانتهاك الواضح
لاتفاقيه جنيف الرابعه هؤلاء الاطفال
الموجودون في عهده روسيا علينا التعامل
معهم كرهائن حتى يتمكنوا من الاتصال
باهاليهم وايجادهم تستخدمهم روسيا لجميع
الاغراض في لعبه خطيره للغايه
حضروا المخيمات الصيفيه التي تمولها روسيا
مئات منهم لم يعودوا الى اسرهم وفقا
للتقرير ومنذ بدء الصراع نقل اطفال بعمر
اربعه اشهر الى ثلاثه
برنامج الترحيل الى تعريف الاطفال
بالتعليم الوطني المتعلق بالجيش الموالي
لروسيا وفقا للتقرير الصادر عن مختبر
الابحاث الانسانيه بجامعه
وتمكن اباء اوكران من استعاده ابنائهم عبر
السفر سرا الى المناطق الخاضعه للروس او
عن طريق توكيل شبكات سريه من المتطوعين
المناهضين لبوتين كالربح النووي العربيه